people can't stop comparing this  Olympian to Leonardo DiCaprio that's  trending but it's trending all right  this is Brady Ellison he's a three-time  Olympian and he helped the u.s. win a  silver medal and archery on Saturday but  his looks have everyone saying he looks  a whole lot like Leo that's all beyond  our control  check out this side-by-side we totally  see it especially when you see them both  in baseball hats but when Brady takes  off his cap the comparisons are a little  more far-fetched still it's pretty funny  it was an unforgettable experience Brady  will be vying for Gold's on Tuesday when  he competes in the individual archery  competition